the lies that blind that's the focus of
tonight's angle
now you can't say that trump didn't warn
everyone about
what would happen to our southern border
if biden won the white house
biden has pledged to open borders he
even said maybe we'll rip down the wall
can you believe it let's take down the
wall let everybody pour into our country
our opponents want open borders open
borders if you don't have borders you
don't have a country
well migrants criminals human
traffickers drug kingpins
all were ecstatic when biden won the
white house
they know he was doing everything in his
power
president trump during pre-covert to
keep america from being deluged with
cheap labor and illegal alien criminals
and it all paid off border crossing
sharply declined as trump turned
migrants away in his last year in office
due to covid and then also sent
potential asylum seekers to wait in
mexico
for their hearings now of course the
border wall another major deterrent to
illegal crossings
would have been finished had trump won
the fact is
biden's win was also a huge win for
cartels and for
anyone who didn't want to go through
legal channels to get here
what i want for my people i just want
patient and pets that we can get to the
us because they're having a new
president
where's biden he's going to help all of
us he's given us
a hundred days to get to the u.s would
you have tried to do this
when donald trump was president
definitely not
definitely so did you come here because
joe biden was elected president
basically basically
but now the entire situation has just
blown up at the border with so many
people coming in that the border patrol
is completely overwhelmed facilities
overflowing and unsanitary
there are now reportedly fifteen
thousand minor migrants in u.s custody
sleeping on mats and on the floors with
tin foil blankets
according to the washington post
children as young as five
are being separated from their parents
when you have congresswoman sheila
jackson lee worried you know it's bad
that the biden administration has met
with members of congress they have a
plan
the plan does not look like it's working
at this time
at this time it's not working and
arizona's kristen cinema
she signed a letter urging biden to take
aggressive steps
to secure our border while failing to
report the simple facts about what lacks
border enforcement means
the media are complicit in the creation
of this crisis
they demonize trump for years on
immigration
with woefully biased and accurate
reporting and now
they're trying to save their own
reputations check out a few of these
headlines the ap
biden is on his heels amid a migrant
surge at the mexico border
nbc immigration challenges mount for
biden
amid migrant influx and finally after
several weeks of white house
stonewalling on allowing media access to
detention facilities
the media are kicking up a minor fuss
the associated press has requested
access to border facilities for more
than a month
reporters first asked hhs on february
4th to allow entry into a surge facility
reopened
at carrizo springs texas holding
hundreds of teenagers
and they've asked homeland security
officials for access at least seven
times to border patrol facilities
with no response even pro
amnesty congressman henry cuellar of
texas was so
frustrated that he released his own
photos of the camps
now here's one of them now gone are the
wire fencing or cages you see replaced
with plexiglass
and plastic now the white house clearly
wants to stall opening up these camps to
the media
as long as possible
when will reporters be allowed to tour
facilities
holding children who cross the southern
border we are working to finalize
details and i hope to have an update in
the coming days
we remain committed to transparency and
of course as i noted
last week we certainly want to make sure
that uh the media has
access uh to uh these uh sites
okay there's no way to put this except
this is a total and complete lie
they could have opened these sites on
day one just blur out the kids faces if
you're worried about privacy
back in may of 2019 the trump
administration allowed
this show to go into border facilities
in texas
they believed in transparency unlike the
current president
there was no reason to hide anything but
it's different now
because the biden administration knows
that the conditions inside
are horrific and they know biden risks
coming off as a total fraud on this
issue
because let's not forget back in july
2019
he was the guy railing against trump's
border detention policy
saying trump's immigration policies are
an assault on human dignity
we are in a country that denies children
soap and a toothbrush
this is not who we are but apparently
that pletsy glass thing that's who we
are
biden's media groupies echoed as much as
biden did back in 2019 and
they just repeated the same lies now
they're all caught with their pants down
exposed but it's too late nevertheless
biden still thinks he can lie his way
out of this
do you have to say quite clearly don't
come
yes i can say quite clearly don't come
on what we're in the process of getting
set up
and it's not going to take a whole long
time is to be able to apply for asylum
in place so don't leave
your town our city or community
of course no one believes him not the
migrants who fly biden flags over their
camps in tijuana
not businesses that desperately want
more cheap labor and are going to get it
and certainly not anyone who's followed
politics over the past couple of decades
so why we return to 2019 for just one of
the reasons
we're a nation says if you want to flee
and you're fleeing oppression
you should come and they did
but what's really important now and this
is key my friends
republicans must avoid making a bad
situation worse
i'm talking republicans on capitol hill
democrats now want to use the crisis
that they are
solely responsible for to force the
hands of gop members on immigration
amnesty
hell no they will not because you cannot
negotiate
border legislation with people who don't
believe in borders
and the people who continue to tell
blatant lies to the faces of the
american people
the border is closed we are expelling
families we are expelling single
adults the man goes on national tv
and says the border is closed when we're
on pace to break a 20-year record for
the most migrant crossings
more than a hundred thousand people in
february alone
and by the way that's nearly triple the
number under trump
in february 2020. now majorcas has lost
all credibility and if protecting
americans mattered more to biden than
catering to the cheap labor lobby
mallorcas would have already been fired
heck of a job ali
but confident that a placid press corps
will cover for them every step of the
way
the biden team thinks that they can
skate past this crisis
by just calling it a challenge democrats
are confident
in their minds that the american people
are not going to hold them accountable
for blowing
what's it going to end up you know it is
being billions of dollars
in taxpayer money to feed educate and
house an endless stream of migrants from
poor countries
when's the last time by the way you've
been in a hotel in the past year
for years democrats worked to undermine
any of us who called for strong border
enforcement
who warned that migrants were exploiting
the asylum laws and
unsw scrupulous employers were in turn
exploiting the migrants
the left viciously attacked trump as
racist and anti-immigrant
for doing the very things that got our
border under control
and in just eight weeks the biden
administration's policies
are directly hurting americans by
lowering the entry level wages
those first-time job seekers i'm talking
about jobs in retail
construction work elder and child care
jobs that used to be filled by americans
are now dominated by mostly foreign
labor
and there's no end in sight at least
until the democrats are beaten
badly in the next election they will
never
enforce the border aggressively never
they'll talk beefed up sensors and
cameras along the border but that's
always been a ruse
just to speed up catch and release the
current crisis is something that will
change our country forever just what the
open border zealots always wanted but
couldn't admit
they conceal instead of reveal their
true intentions
which brings us to the ultimate biden
lie
i promise you watch i always
try to do what i say i'm gonna do if i
make a mistake i'll tell you i made a
mistake
and i'll take responsibility
ah he's so authentic even on zoom
now just remember the whole time that
they were telling americans to stay home
slow the spread mask up and avoid other
people
these same people were encouraging
everyone in the rest of the world
to come here as quickly as possible and
that's the angle